I was appointed chair 18 months ago this
instant but then the Haiti story broke
in the first three months of my time as
chair I regarded it as my duty and
responsibility to stay with Oxfam and to
try and help sort it out and so that's
why I'm sitting here today okay what
more then in terms of your personal
reaction given that what's being
described here over a long period of
time and perhaps not just in Haiti is it
there's a kind of sex for aid operation
are you ashamed of that
I'm thoroughly ashamed of it and I want
to say sorry I want to apologize to the
people of Haiti to the people who were
affected and the survivors of that
behavior but also to our donors and
supporters in Britain because we let
them down we let down everyone in those
circumstances it was a shameful incident
and it should never have been allowed to
happen and should have been stopped
earlier than it was so presumably you
accept them from the Charity Commission
this official warning you feel it is
deserved
yeah the Charity Commission have done 18
months of exhaustive inquiry into Oxfam
we cooperated with it fully and we
accept all its recommendations it makes
for really uncomfortable reading for us
but it's possibly the better for that
because I think we deserve having been
made to feel uncomfortable we deserve
some tough judgements and we are going
to follow them and learn from them
but you didn't initially I mean that's
in the report as well isn't it that it's
taken Oxfam awhile to respond they were
still unhappy with Oxfam's response up
to 2017 now you say it's all going to
can the change and improve and can never
happen again but can we believe you
given that Oxfam didn't seem to have
acted quickly enough in the first
instance it's true that post Haiti we
didn't go far enough fast enough in our
investment in safeguarding I think the
people then felt that they were doing
more and they were already investing
more and more money but the truth is it
wasn't enough and I think people didn't
really understand the full depth of the
problem of safeguarding the cultural
problem that you had within Oxfam the
there was a very fundamental problem
here which needed more fundament
measures to treat it we are now doing
that we are now we've tripled the amount
of money we're spending on safeguarding
we've got a hundred investigators
trained based in every country which we
work in around the world we've put every
single member of staff through online
safeguarding training we are beginning
to make the moves now at the sort of
level and scale which I think will make
a difference but unfortunately that
wasn't done earlier but where are you
okay are taking that on board where are
you then in this process that the
Charity Commission describes so that you
need further cultural and systemic
change you saying that actually has
occurred or now they all got some way to
go we've still got somewhere to go as
cultural and they are right to say we
need cultural and systemic change that
is a very difficult thing to deliver it
means putting some a good solid
foundation there and so implementing the
recommendations they've made 79
recommendations we've already
implemented well over 2/3 of them that
will help give us the foundation and the
base from which to change but the real
change we need to make and why I'm
particularly pleased that we've had put
so many members of staff through
safeguarding training is we need to stop
to get a culture which feels that
somehow safeguarding is something that's
done by directors of safeguarding the
safeguarding is something that's that's
for investigation and understand that
it's about creating the right culture
and environment in which people can work
and it's the responsibility of every
person who works in Oxfam whether there
are a trustee or a receptionist or a an
aid worker out and out in the field
everyone needs to be working to create
the right environment of transparency of
safety and safety is not just about
stopping these things occurring but
crucially about creating an environment
where people feel they can report them
it's a huge bureaucratic operation then
isn't it you mentioned there the huge
number of extra staff you're going to
have to recruit to to oversee this and
ultimately that means with with a
shrinking pot I know that less money is
going to go on aids in its it does
require more money and I think one of
the things we need to do and we already
started doing is having conversations
with donors particular with
institutional donors about how we make
sure that we have enough funds from the
money they give them to ensure that we
work in the right
sort of safe environment and can deliver
the safety that everyone is but as a
proportion of I don't know what what it
is it's a proportion of the funds you
get in and how much is spent on the
front line which is what all donors want
to see in all child ease isn't it as
much as possible where it's going to be
most effective some of that has to be
diverted then now does it not we've have
a target of only deliver only spending
ten percent of our income on overheads
and on administration it may be that
that has to extend to 11 or 12 percent
in order to account to encourage and and
make sure that we deliver on this I
think everyone would agree that that
would be money really well spent
because creating the safe environment
for our beneficiaries and for our staff
is really absolutely crucial and what
are your concerns about the fact that
Haiti may not be alone incident has
already been discussion about Oxfam and
similar types of activities in Chad now
given the the scores for one imagines
that the hundreds of countries that
Oxfam has operated in over the decades
you've got a huge investigative task
Avenue we've just trained the hundred
investigators who are out there in all
our countries where we're operating in
order to try to make sure that we we
understand what is happening we do I
cannot sit here and promise that these
sort of incidents will never occur in
the future because we operate in some of
the most dangerous territories in the
world they are lawless areas we have
made were kurz at the moment risking
their lives helping Ebola sufferers in
the Democratic Republic of Congo
we have people being bombed every night
in Yemen these are these are very tricky
areas and it is very difficult to
absolutely be sure everything every time
what is that what is happening there
what we need to do is to create the
right culture which makes such
activities such as sexual abuse
unthinkable or less thinkable or and a
culture as well where people feel safe
to report it and that's crucial and
that's terribly difficult in in the
field and then a culture where we where
once it's reported we properly
investigate and we properly hold people
to account
and people lose their jobs over it okay
lastly the issue the issue of donations
what would you say to those people say
why should I donate to Oxfam after all
this all we've heard over the last 18
months and now this report why should I
give this charity my money I would say
that this report is an illustration of
how Oxfam is changing and that we have
cooperated fully with it it has taken 18
months we are opening up Oxfam in a
process of transparency to the absolute
rigorous and very painful light of day
so we can understand what went wrong and
how we can put it right so this is part
of the healing and rebuilding process
what I would ask them to do is to judge
us on how we rebuild how we respond in
the next six months to the Charity
Commission requirements and then how we
respond beyond that for the next two or
three years in really making Oxfam a
place fit for the middle of the twin and
also in terms of donations for
government it's talked about Oxfam and
its failing to meet those high standards
would you say to the government now that
it's money would be well spent with
Oxfam I would hope that the government
government would shortly have confidence
that they could give us money again we
are pleased that USAID the Americans are
giving I've restored funding as have the
Swedes the Swedish Development Agency we
we've obviously got a big issue in
Britain about restoring trust because we
are a British institution so I
completely understand that for the
government the decision made may take
some time but I would hope that this is
as I say the first step on the way to
getting back to there our normal
relations with the British government
and British government funding